okay you were like making headlines
um at the SAG Awards so you played
Chessie the nanny in The Parent Trap I
did with Lindsay Lowe yeah
and you went to the SAG Awards with
Elaine Hendricks who plays the Stepmom I
did she's my best friend she was the the
mean girlfriend and I hated her in the
movie but yes we met the first day of
shooting and we were both dating guys
that weren't really showing up for the
relationship you guys know how that is
so anyway we sat down and we started
talking at Marie Calendars I had just
quit drinking oh my gosh Marie
Callender's and congratulations on the
drinking that was a minute ago but yeah
right thank you so I just stopped
drinking but
boom um so uh being a mom that's really
for me what it was it was like I was
going through a divorce and oh my God me
too yeah oh my God you guys we're gonna
have a conversation sees us we'll be
right back but um so I had just had a
breakup and it was not a really good
time in my life and when my mother got
divorced she fell apart because in those
days people especially like Sicilian
women you know Italians that culture you
didn't really divorce and she was so
wrecked that she started drinking and I
was it scared me it was very scary for a
kid to have a mother that wasn't present
that was passing out so I said I can't
be that for my kids I have to be
entirely present so I quit drinking but
I was eating pies I ate an entire pie at
Marie Callender because every single one
of those pies thank you that's so
perceptive about what didn't work in
your childhood and no judgment my mother
was it was just a trauma for her so no
judgment I never finished the rest of
the question okay thank you I'll take it
thank you
I'm like oh my God I am not getting out
of this show without a Drew hug I'm
getting I I've got so many for you okay
so you're eating Marie Callender's pies
with Elaine Hendricks yes and and we
just bonded immediately we became best
friends we've stayed friends over the
years I've been with her through her
breakups vice versa I've helped move her
into every home she's ever had and I
mean physically like carrying boxes and
um it's like flipping a disc yes exactly
right so the 20th anniversary of The
Parent Trap five years ago this is the
25th and they weren't really doing
anything at the studio Disney really
didn't do anything so we Lane and I had
a viewing party where she got us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter all at
the same time I'm in La she's in New
York and we just had the fans watch it
with us as we like talk through it and
that was great but I think hopefully
this year they'll do something I don't
know I haven't heard anything well they
should I mean I watch that movie all the
time with my kids and I love the Haley
Mills one like The Parent Trap is but
Nancy Myers you guys it just it's a
master class film and it's so joyful
please do something for them okay do you
hear that Disney yeah I think we'll do
something on the show okay
yes
um I okay so sorry we skipped around I
apologize we did well okay so are you
open to being in a relationship uh a
hundred percent I'm open and looking I
just I just live in Los Angeles the land
where prom queens go to die
what are looking for and where are you
looking out of curiosity because I'm
single too and I'm doing the same thing
you know what I think as we get older
when you're young you're like I want the
prince charming and he's got to be six
foot three and he had blue eyes and
brown hair look like Henry Cavill like
you have a whole list and then this gets
real short yeah right I'm like I want
them to be kind of beefy because I like
feeding people because I'm Italian so I
want to I don't want you to have a heart
attack tomorrow but I'm like a beefy guy
right you know like later in life
Russell Crowe like beefy yeah and also
not someone who's like the guy version
of like I'll have the salad no not that
right you can't be prettier than me I
did that once okay not a good idea no no
gym muscles but I just want them to be
funny and that doesn't mean he's got to
make jokes he just has to laugh at
everything I say right exactly I think
they call that a sense of humor yeah
well a lot of guys will say I want a
funny woman and what they mean is
somebody laughs at my dumb jokes that's
what that means right so just a sense of
humor and maybe a job it would be good
those three things that's it
I I are we the same person 100 because
everything tracks so far I am looking
for someone with a sense of humor nice
who's who has a passion and a job and is
employed and distracted and busy right
and yeah kind yeah that's it those are
my three okay you hear that America
let's go get on it
but um so I'm looking at
I'm looking on the dating apps which I
hate dating apps are hard but they're
like the only thing that I the only
dates I've gone on in the last few years
is from a dating app like nobody's asked
me out in real life does anyone does any
men here feel comfortable asking a woman
out in the real world
one guy one guy right there he does
great you raise your hand but he's not
single I bet you're not single right I
know I'm single oh you are yeah okay we
got a shot what's your name uh sorry uh
I'm Luke can I ask you why you think so
many
at least for women's perspective it
seems like no guys are ever asking us
out in real life anymore do you think
it's because of dating apps because
there's like a very specific portal to
get accepted and rejected and we don't
have to do that anymore
I think the fear of rejection is
probably the biggest Factor yeah that's
what I would assume too
and also I think that there is an
assumption that I don't have what it
would take like you you have your life
together you've got this amazing show
you've got your brands that you do and
they're like I don't have enough because
historically women traded we had Youth
and beauty that was our commodity and
men had this is what I can make I give
it to you now the world has changed but
human beings and they're in their sort
of biological imperative their genetic
imprint don't change that quick so men
are like oh I don't earn enough I can't
I can't compete with that but that they
overly try to impress you is what I
found like on Match or wherever I go
they'll say stuff like well I just got
my pilot's license I'll take you up and
I'm like no I don't I don't want to play
Russian Roulette and your Cessna Greg
like you're like you just got your
license like
take it easy okay I don't want to play
Russian Roulette in your Cessna Greg is
my new favorite sentence of 2023. thank
you thank you Luke
okay I am obsessed with this woman I
don't want to have to go to break but we
have to be right back
[Music]
foreign